heute führt unser gast moderator daniel
cohn bendit das letzte von insgesamt
drei gesprächen in der sternstunde
philosophie von deutschland über die
schweiz nach österreich nach juli zeh
und peter von matt ist nun die wiener
schriftstellerin eva menasse zu gast
ihr neuestes buch heißt quasikristalle
damit gemeint sind kristalle die unter
der oberfläche keine klare und
einheitliche struktur haben sondern
vielgestaltig sind sie sind sozusagen
fragmentarisch und unsere biografien bzw
die menschliche identität eva menasse
und daniel cohn bendit begeben sich auf
quasikristalle suche hallo wir versuchen
heute mit sie ja soll ich klappte es vom
in asse sind wienerin leben in berlin
dh es sind sie auf der flucht weg von
österreich
es war auf der flucht damals als ich mir
dringend gewünscht habe österreich
verlassen zu können und ein größeres
land zu ziehen
das war der wunsch hat begonnen in
meinen mittleren 20ern und als ich es
dann geschafft habe war ich erleichtert
aber inzwischen habe ich mein verhältnis
zu österreich glaube ich halbwegs
entspannt ja gut okay wir kommen darauf
zurück aber in wenn man in ihre
biografien ließ dann wird sagt sie hätte
jüdisch-christliche vorfahren das klingt
so rational wenn man da bis sie näher
eingehen also eine wie einen wienerisch
jüdischen großvater der seiner ehefrau
eine sudetendeutsche katholiken
eigentlich das überlegen aus dem
holocaust verdammt einen vater der
eigentlich nicht jude ist
nach jüdischer definition weil aber da
muss ich gleich wieder sprechen weil das
stimmt eben nicht für die damalige zeit
mein vater es 1930 geboren worden und
vor dem nationalsozialismus und den
holocaust waren dieser regeln gelockert
das judentum hat sich begonnen zu
liberalisieren und das war eine
entscheidung der eltern da hat auch kein
rabbiner nachgefragt das war ist ein
großes thema in meiner familie gewesen
deswegen möchte ich das unbedingt
betonen
mein vater hat sich auch zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt seines lebens
gefragt aber eigentlich jude ist weil
warum hätte er dann emigrieren müssen
das sind zusammen in die kultusgemeinde
gegangen wir sind ins archiv gegangen
wir haben uns das erklären lassen
wenn jemand wie mein großvater 1930
seinen sein drittes kind irgendwo da ein
drittes kind geboren
dann ging er an die kultusgemeinde hat
registrieren lassen damit war jude
sowohl für die juden wie auch für die
nationalsozialisten vater habe
christliche mutter der vater dann noch
logischer 38 geben nach england mit dem
kinde transporten überlebt also lebt
dann während des krieges in london oder
in england kommt zurück nach wien in den
50er jahren wird er ist er fußballer es
spielt auch für die österreichische
nationalmannschaft folgt immer jemanden
kennenlernen will sein vater
nationalspieler also fußball
nationalspieler ist haben sie davon was
mitbekommen
es war ja ein bisschen danach sind sie
geboren haben sie von diesem fußball
fieber in der familie also etwas geerbt
das fußballfieber besteht bis heute
mein vater gehört zu den wenigen
menschen die so verrückt sind dass sie
sich fußballspieler die er versäumt weil
etwas anderes vorhat im fernsehen auf
mit dem video recorder aufzeichnen und
danach anschaut und menschen zu köpfen
bereit wäre die irrtümlich das ergebnis
vorher verraten
also dieser fußball dieses fußballfieber
ist natürlich kennzeichnet übrigens auch
tennis fieber also sportfieber insgesamt
ich war in meiner kindheit mit meinem
vater eine zeit lang fiel am
fußballplatz da ich habe so eine phase
gehabt wollte ich vielleicht ihm
gefallen aber ich habe mich auch dafür
interessiert und bis heute habe ich ein
fußball eine große fußball-begeisterung
eine blöde frage für wen
sind sie das ist klar dass diese frage
jetzt ja denn es würden hier immer
gestellt ich weiß warum ich sie dennoch
nicht erkennen ob ich für deutschland
und frankreich wird also für wen sie da
österreich seit ich mich erinnern kann
in keinem internationalen wettbewerben
mehr mitspielt weil es nirgends die
qualifikation schafft dieses leicht
jetzt für deutschland zu sein mein
sohnes deutschland sie ist geschafft uns
jetzt nach na ja ich bin mir nicht
sicher die haben es selbst wenn sie
schon sicher gehabt haben haben sie es
immer noch vergeigt also ich bezweifle
es in österreich aber gegen deutschland
spielt was ja auch nur alle jubeljahre
mal vorkommt dann bin ich aus fatalismus
und aus verzweiflung und aus einem rest
patriotismus immer für österreich auch
weil ich mir denke es wäre schön wenn
einmal david gegen goliath gewinnt aber
ist es nicht schön dass der beste
österreichische spieler heute ein
schwarzer ist das ist alaba das ist neu
das gibt ein jude war mal im fünfziger
jahre und jetzt ein schwarzer also und
es hat glaubt irgend einen
österreichischen politiker gegeben der
den alaba bei einem kennenlernen auf
englisch angesprochen hat kennen sie
diese geschichte ja sehr lustig wenn wir
jetzt mal zurückgehend jänner fast ja
ihr buch jänner fast ja eigentlich auf
diese geschichte oder als ist sagen sie
sie übernehmen teile ihrer eigenen
geschichte geschichte ihrer familie um
dieses hof jänner zu schreiben und was
mich da immer interessiert ist dass sie
plötzlich dinge sagen also sie
beschreiben dass wien und dann ein jude
und dann sozusagen sagen sie ihr
großvater glaube ich war das der sagt
spazieren gehen was soll ich dann
spinnen doch kein reja ist ein jude
gehört oder ein die ende wieder gehört
ins kaffeehaus ist das für sie im grunde
genommen sowie identitäts mäßig ein
widerspruch zu österreichischen
identität ja wien ist nicht österreich
das ist klar wien ist ja das tragische
beispiel einer großstadt die iris groß
reiches verluste gegangen ist und
deswegen gibt es ja auch dieser
merkwürdige spannung zwischen der großen
stadt und dem kleinen rest land das 1918
verblieben ist
ja was heißt es wenn sie schreiben der
erste seit mein vater ist eine
sturzgeburt das stimmt so das bedeutet
dass eine sturzgeburt einer sturzgeburt
bedeutet wenn eine frau schon viele
kinder geboren hat und die wir sonst an
die bänder schon etwas ausgeleiert sind
dass das kind ein bisschen zu schnell
herausrutscht wo der letzte satz ist
mein sohn ist eine sturzgeburt sagte die
großmutter die großmutter er ist die
klammer des romans genau ist das leben
eine sturzgeburt ja vermutlich ist das
leben auch irgendwie eine sturzgeburt
wird man weiß ja nie was kommt und man
fällt in etwas herein was man sich nicht
ausgesucht hat ist die familie sie haben
die neben familie geschichte und dann
machen sie eine fiktionale geschichte
es genügt die familiengeschichte nicht
oder ist die fiktion die möglichkeit
eigentlich familie zu transzendieren die
fiktion ist immer die möglichkeit dinge
zu erfinden die das ganze sichtbarer
machen lassen das ist eine jede familie
der welt und sei es die interessanteste
und lustigste familie ist nicht lustig
und interessant genug für einen roman
das heißt die fiktion muss ja immer
verdichten auswählen umbauen und das
daraus ergibt sich ja diese spannung das
ist eben nie die eigene familie die in
einem buch dargestellt wird
aber in dieser in dieser
familiengeschichte fangen sie an das
finden wir ja dann später immer fallen
der immer an oder suchen sie oder wo ist
die identität oder was die identität
eines bestimmten menschen und es ist ja
eigentlich nicht so greifbar oder es
verändert sich ja immer im lauf der zeit
es geht erst mal nicht um die identität
sondern ich habe diesen roman
geschrieben sozusagen als nebenprodukt
meiner suche nach einer gewissen
familien wahrheit als junger mensch
denkt man ich bin dazu von inzwischen
lange abgekommen
dass es irgendwas wie so eine
überprüfbare geschichte mit festem rand
gibt und nach der ich gesucht dann in
unserer familie wie in vielen anderen
familien ist die nazi zeit geschwiegen
worden man hat darüber nicht geredet ja
das war vorbei und das war auch für die
opfer vorbei
das war gut für die opfer dass es vorbei
war deswegen wollten sie auch nicht mehr
darüber reden
also das war der impuls diesen roman zu
schreiben die sich dann eben drauf
gekommen bin dass es nicht so einfach
geht und einen roman schreiben musste
weil es sozusagen für das für die kleine
familienchronik die sozusagen ein
sachbuch gewesen wäre sich zu wenig
wahrheiten haben festklopfen lassen aber
wer hat ihr vater dann erklärt dass er
in england war wenn über diese
geschichte nicht geredet wurde
das hat überhaupt nicht erklärt als ich
ein kleines kind war also so ungefähr im
alter meines sohnes jetzt im
grundschulalter hat es immer geheißen
der paprika kann perfekt englisch darauf
waren wir stolz als kinder weil niemand
von den vätern meiner schulkameraden
englisch konnte das war nicht in den
70er jahren dass jemand englisch konnte
noch dazu perfekt und der partie ist ist
aufgewachsen in england und natürlich
fragt man dann irgendwann als kind und
man kriegt aber ausweichende antworten
sozusagen das ganze drama das dahinter
steckte
dass man da ein kind mit einem
namensschild um den hals mit acht jahren
in einem zug setzt vermutlich in dem in
der sicheren überzeugung ist nie wieder
zu sehen
das hatte ich mir alles erst viel später
erschlossen und sie haben ja vorhin
erzählt sie sehen mit ihrem vater der
jüdischen gemeinde und haben das
nachgeprüft mit dem jüdisch oder nicht
wie die das habe ich vor allem für ihn
gemacht ich hatte das schon damals mit
historikern besprochen dass das eben in
der zwischenkriegszeit anders wahr dass
man dass die juden das selbst in den
großen städten wie wien viel liberaler
damit umgegangen sind wenn der jüdische
haushaltsvorstand gesagt hat meine
kinder sind juden dann hat keiner
rabbiner gefragt wer ist eigentlich die
mutter dazu das ist heute anders weil
die juden nach der shoa ein viel
stärkeres bedürfnis haben sich zu
definieren und damit auch von den
anderen abzugreifen
sie sind hier christlich erzogen
einführung spricht oder gehalt sind in
die kirche gegangen oder ich bin getauft
worden und habe meiner erstkommunion mit
acht jahren erlebt und damit war meine
katholische karriere dann zu ändern
also zu der firmung und dem rest hat
mich meine mutter nicht mehr gezwungen
und
ist jetzt ihr verhältnis oder hat sich
entwicklung judentum also irgendwie war
judentum irgendwo dann haben sie
plötzlich entdeckt das ist auch in ihrer
geschichte und wo steckt ja meine
kindheit war bestimmt von juden und
christen ich habe eben diese jüdisch
dieser jüdischen jüdischen teil mein
großvater hat relativ stark gehebelt
nicht nicht nicht so wie simon
wiesenthal aber so dazwischen ja ja ja
mit welcher selbst und meine großmutter
die die sudetendeutsche die katholiken
hat am ende ihres lebens genauso wie
lidl trier machen die aber das ist
normal ja erika steinbach glaubt frau
erika steinbach möchte ich gar nichts
eigentlich wenn man mich persönlich
fragt auf der anderen seite war meine
polnische großmutter extrem katholische
und dazwischen sind wir aufgewachsen wir
waren nie in der kirche meiner mutter
hat dass das war kennen das hat keine
rolle gespielt also ich hab das eine
minimale rudimentäre katholische
erziehung erlebt wie gesagt bis zu
meinem achten lebensjahr auf der anderen
seite war ich aber fasziniert von den
vielen juden mit denen man freunden
meinen vater befreundet war
ich erinnere mich an den berühmten onkel
freddy ein slowakischer jude von dem es
heißt er sei aus dem zug nach auschwitz
gesprungen aber sie wissen ja das sind
alles diese mythen die die man sich dann
nachher so auch da ist da hat irgendwie
so irgendwas gut gegangen und dann macht
man so eine geschichte daraus die
eigentlich nicht stimmen kann
denn ich glaube es gibt niemanden der
seine zu aber egal diese menschen mit
denen bin ich aufgewachsen mit dem jeden
großvater mit den anderen juden mein
vater war ja dann in diesem tennisclub
der bis heute besteht wo auch
komischerweise sehr viele juden neben
sehr vielen antisemiten bis heute sitzen
und kartenspiel das ist ein typisches
wiener phänomen also es war so eine
gemischte identität und ich kann nur
sagen das kommt ja auch irgendwie aus
einem selber es hat doch was charakter
irgendwas charakterliche was man nicht
erklären kann wo das dann in die eine
richtung er sozusagen die waagschale
sich senkt in meinem fall war es dass
ich mich sehr früh mit der geschichte
meines vaters zu beschäftigen begonnen
habe
sehr viel dazu gelesen habe versucht
etwas herauszufinden alles das was hat
mit meinem sozusagen mit 18 20 begonnen
und hat dann sehr sehr viele jahre
später wiederum in diesem roman mal was
interessant ist kann man nicht sagen
dass sie sich im grunde genommen
irgendwann eine identität ausgesuchte
ich habe sie mir nicht ausgesucht denn
ich bin ja weiterhin sozusagen
fragwürdig zwischen den stühlen
ich habe mit 18 20 die erfahrung gemacht
dass meint dass ich das meine
katholischen also ordentlich in
österreich ja sozusagen schon gewusst
haben dass da mit meinem vater irgend
etwas nicht koscher war genau und auf
der anderen seite die ersten jüdischen
studenten die ich kennengelernt habe
die haben ja auch zu verstehen gegeben
dass ich nicht ganz zu ihnen gehören
beziehungsweise die haben dann so
inquisitorische fragen nach meiner
großmutter nach meiner mutter gestellt
ja also ich habe sehr früh bemerkt dass
ich irgendwie nie irgendwo ganz dazu
gehört und das war mir aber kein problem
sondern eigentlich jetzt im nachhinein
eine bereicherung das heißt für sie wenn
sie jetzt von dem vor der situation
stehen dass ihr sohn sieben jahre
irgendwann werden sie in die
familiengeschichte ist umfang
familiengeschichte erzählen wie gehen
sie damit um was was versuchen sie ihm
zu vermitteln also oder was wären sie
komischerweise oder passender war also
vielleicht leben wir in berlin in einem
viertel wo das ganze viertel ein
gedenkort es stimmt es gibt immer das
bayerische viertel in berlin schöneberg
das ganze viertel ist eingedenk ort und
das heißt dass an jeder straßenlaterne
einer eine eine tafel hängt damit an
ja die sind aber die sind ja in ganz
berlin aber bei uns sind nicht sie ist
die antijüdische gesetzgebung aus der
nazi zeit an jedem laternenpfahl
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt für mich
auch nicht ganz unproblematisch die paar
anderen juden die da heute leben also
oder ich bin ja nur halbjahr
gewissermaßen die finden das auch
komisch denn ich bin mit meinem sohn
drei jahre lang einmal um die ecke in
den kindergarten gegangen ich glaube das
sind 300 meter zu fuß und ausgerechnet
auf der strecke war der der gesetzt
gesetzestext kinder ab sechs jahren
müssen den stern tragen ja weiß ich
nicht so und so viel dass september 42
oder keine ahnung 1 38 keine ahnung und
an diesem schild bin ich jeden tag
vorbei gegangen
jetzt ist er drei jetzt muss er noch
nicht ja also es ist ja automatisch dass
wenn man von diesen gesetzen betroffen
gewesen wäre man sie immer noch für sich
irgendwie gültig hält oder anders gesagt
dieses viertel in dem wir leben ist
eines ist ein gedenkort der davon
ausgeht dass es gar keine juden mehr
gibt und dass man also die die die
deutschen nicht juden immer daran
erinnern muss was sie böses gemacht
haben aber über diese sachen muss ich
sozusagen mit meinem sohn sprechen vor
allem also noch sehr klein war hat er
sich immer mit diesem stolpersteinen
beschäftigt weil er über die möglichen
leuten gegangen ist ja erhält sie bis
heute für grabsteine und kann den unter
stolpersteine ist muss man vielleicht
erklären in den deutschen städten in
einigen in einigen berlin frankfurt
münchen sollten münchen gibt es so
steine wo gesagt wird hier haben die und
die menschen gelebt bevor sie
importieren
interessant ist jetzt die frage
wenn also es gibt antisemitismus ist
gratis rassismus oder antisemitismus
fühlen sie sich vom antisemitismus
betrug getroffen also wenn dass es auf
sie bezogen ich sage das weil nicht
geben
ich bin zwei jude also vollkommen nach
allen seiten japanischen teile sind alle
gesetze ja
bin aber nie genii zu nico wir mit einem
nicht würdigen verheiratet aber trotzdem
ist judentum für mich so dass wenn es
antisemitismus gibt dann bin ich gut
obwohl ich gar nichts wenn es gegen die
juden geht bin ich dran und wenn das war
interessant was sie von ihren sohn eher
wenig daran dass ihr sohn wer egal
im grunde genommen jetzt wie ihr gelebt
hätte tja 330 oder 41 42 wäre dran
gewesen die einen jüdischen großvater
großelternteil ja wäre schon dran
gewesen
es ist bleibt dabei für mich und
vielleicht kommen wir jetzt zu der zu
ihrem neuen boot also ich sag auch
französische auswahl quasi
quasikristalle das ist ja auch
interessant wie sie im grunde genommen
ist es im roman
sie haben eine person in der hauptperson
und sie
sie wird erzählt in verschiedenen
lebensabschnitten in verschieden
lebensgeschichten
das sind geschichten und dann sieht man
am ende das ist diese person diese
person im grunde genommen durch geht ja
verschiedene lebt in bestimmten
situationen andere identitäten das ist
ja dass das frappierende würden sie am
beispiel jetzt das buch einfach sagen
die haben nicht nur eine identität punkt
aus in dem buch geht es dann muss man
glaube ich ein bisschen genauer sein
geht es um die verschiedenen rollen die
man spielt im leben in dem man eben als
eltern zu seinem kind eine andere rolle
einnimmt als als kind zu seinen eigenen
eltern oder als freund zu seinen
freunden oder als partner zu seinem
partner oder als chef zu seinem
untergebenen oder umgekehrt
um diese rollen geht es erst einmal aber
natürlich ist identität auch immer ein
konstrukt das wir uns anziehen und das
uns angezogen wird
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel als ich mein
erstes buch vienna geschrieben habe hat
mich ein redakteur des bayerischen
fernsehens angerufen er macht gerade
einen film über junge deutsche
ob er mich interviewen kann dann habe
ich gesagt hatte ich bin österreicher in
und so richtig jüdisch bin ich auch
nicht hat er gesagt egal er möchte
kommen soll wenn sich unbedingt kommen
möchten dann kommen sie er kommt baut
seine kamera auf und stellt als erstes
genau wieder diese frage werden telefon
sagt sie als junge deutsche jüdin wie
geht es ihnen so irgendwie ja und ich
mach das normalerweise nicht weil ich
ein guter zogen das mädchen bin aber in
dem moment habe ich gesagt wieder drehen
sie diese kamera ab das gibt's doch
nicht wir haben doch das schon
besprochen ich bin nicht dass alles was
sie sagen dann hat mir der eine lektion
erteilt die ich bis heute nicht
vergessen habt gesagt aber schauen sie
sie schreiben über den holocaust leugner
prozess sie haben in der faz als
journalistin viele artikel geschrieben
über vergangenheitsbewältigung über
neonazis das ist alles ihr themenkreis
gibt schreiben sie einen roman über eine
jüdische familie am zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die leute nehmen sie als
jüdin war jetzt geben sie sich damit
zufrieden und darüber bin ich drei
wochen nicht hinweg gekommen weil mir
klar geworden ist das ist sozusagen für
mich selber das so ganz fein stofflich
auseinanderdividieren kann ich bin ein
bisserl das und ein bisschen jenes aber
ich will mich nirgends aufdrängen und
ich habe nie behauptet juden zu sein es
kommt von außen und sie setzen die einen
sack auf und da bist du darunter ihr
aber dass da sind wir jetzt bei
interessant sie haben sich auch bei dem
boxer so verschieden sie wie erleben sie
in verschiedenen rollen geben was ist
der unterschied zwischen eine rolle die
man hat und eine identität ist es nur
einfach etwas oberflächliches eine rolle
ist ist durchlässiger die kann man viel
schneller wechseln sie können an einem
tag in der früh an ehemann seien dann
ein politiker im europaparlament dann am
nachmittag ein freund der mit seinem
freund zum kaffee geht und so aber
trotzdem haben sie eine identität die
identität ist wird mächtiger würde ich
sagen die identität ist das größere
konzept das schon aber die die identität
ist auch etwas was ich
verändert also sie haben ja zu mir eben
gesagt politiker oder so was ich vor 40
jahren war was ich heute bin
das sind zwei verschiedene menschen nah
wie machen es anders
arbeitgeber-präsident der ermordet wurde
von der raf war ein sozialer mehr oder
weniger sozialer arbeitgeber präsident
in den 70er jahren in deutschland und
war im krieg bei der ss in prag als
besatzungsmacht
es sind zwei menschen das war wir haben
eine identität es sind nicht nur zwei
rollen glaube das ist das schwieriger zu
verstehen ja das ist schwierig zu
verstehen aber dazu bin ich zu wenig
philosophin um das genau auseinander
brüssel zu können die identität kann
sich schleichend verändern so wie ich
gerade gesagt habe dass ich meine
identität dahingehend verändert hat dass
ich verstanden hat dass der jüdische an
teil meiner identität größer ist als ich
es gewusst hab einfach durch die durch
die texte die ich geschrieben habe und
die themen mit denen ich mich
beschäftigt habe trotzdem glaube ich ist
eine identität erst mal auch was inneres
was man selbst sozusagen auch mit
definiert wenn sie zum beispiel meine
schwester fragen würden die hat glaube
ich nicht das geringste
den geringsten anteil von jüdischer
identität in sich oder höchstens einen
ganz klaren sie gesucht
sie haben das ist ja das spannende aber
schon ja das ist es ja eine eine eine
entscheidung sie haben sich in eine
geschichte rheingebiet ja und dann das
identitäts mäßig übernommen
genau dafür gibt es aber ganz
psychoanalytische erklärungen dass in
familien mit holocaust verfolgung es
manchmal in der zweiten generation so
ist das von mehreren kindern eines das
nennt sich mein modell kindle wird und
dann können die anderen sozusagen frei
sein und dieses eine durch überleben
übernimmt dieses gedenkarbeit und die
habe ich
ich glaube eher mehr wollen als 0 1
übernommen das ist deutlich ja
aber wenn man noch mal die geschichte
die rollen von exane roxane hier in die
in ihrem buch der quasikristalle nimmt
das interessante ist dass sie im grunde
genommen
diese person beschreiben durch andere
genau die anderen erleben diese person
und somit kriegen wir so langsam mit wer
roxel eigentlich ist ja jeder sieht was
anderes in ihr und das glaube ich ist in
unserem leben auch wirklich so dass wir
für jeden ein anderer sind man tut man
gut daran ist das nicht allzu oft vor
augen zu führen lässt uns wird man
schwindlig sagte hat mal war hat mal hat
geschrieben berühmten seiten auf erzählt
die hölle sind die anderen
das heißt so wie die anderen einem sehen
dass das kann die hölle oder das ist
sehr oft die hölle ist das so dass im
grunde genommen man total abhängig ist
von den was wie die anderen einem sehen
und wenn man ein bisschen
opportunistisch ist das ist
wahrscheinlich jeder mehr oder weniger
dann versucht man auch in eine rolle
hineinzuschlüpfen ihm an wie die anderen
ein gern hätte ja aber das ist eine
interaktion ich gehe ja auch auf den
anderen auf eine ganz bestimmte weise zu
wenn ich jemanden kennenlerne
entscheidet sich das mögen oder nicht
mögen in wenigen sekunden dann kann man
das natürlich noch ein bisschen
verfeinern aber diese wenigen sekunden
geben ja genauso viel aufschluss darüber
wie der andere mir gegenüber ist als
auch wie ich selbst bin nämlich was habe
ich für erfahrungen gemacht
an den erinnert mich dieser mensch der
jetzt mein plötzliches gegenüber ist bin
ich eher selbstbewusst wie bin ich
erzogen worden wie es mein charakter und
nicht zuletzt wie es meiner tagesform
wenn ich einer ganz schlechten tag hat
kann mir eigentlich jeder freundlicher
mensch wahnsinnig auf die nerven gehen
und wenn ich einen guten tag habe halte
ich auch noch ein schreckliches
arschloch irgendwie ganz gut aus das
sind interaktionen genauso wie wir die
wir rollen von außen angetragene
bekommen und sie das ist richtig aus
opportunismus teilweise annehmen
so sind wir ja auch zu den an
das heißt da gibt es keinen die an
sozusagen die anderen die uns da
investieren und und wir können gar
nichts dagegen tun sondern wir sind ja
ununterbrochen in diesem zweikampf mit
dem mit den mitmenschen befangen und das
formt unseren charakter und am ende
wahrscheinlich auch unsere identität
jetzt komme ich so meine anfangsphase
zurück dann als wienerin in berlin
flucht oder nicht flucht was ist ihnen
also sagen wir was ist ihnen auf die
nerven gegangen
wien oder österreich und warum haben sie
lange sie leben sind wenn 13 jahren 13
jahre später vielleicht einen anderen
blick darauf und vielleicht sogar eine
sehnsucht auf berlin
sehnsucht würde ich das immer noch nicht
nennen wollen naja das hat das hat
natürlich viel auch mit meinem beruf zu
tun ich war damals journalistin
ich habe in einem großen
österreichischen oder eigentlich dem
einzig anständigen österreichischen
nachrichten- magazin gearbeitet profil
und ich wollte und ich war mitte 20 und
hat sozusagen auf diesem gebiet schon so
viel geschafft gehabt dass ich wissen
wollte ob ich das in einem größeren land
auch noch auch schaffen würde ich wollte
gerne nach deutschland weil ich das
gefühl gehabt hat da ist journalistisch
einfach mehr stoff mehr platz mehr
möglichkeiten
das war schon ein grund dass an der
andere grund ist dass wien aus
historischen gründen natürlich sehr
auch damals noch kurz nach dem fall des
eisernen vorhangs irgendwie im eigenen
sud gekocht ist das war
da hat es nicht viel austausch gegeben
mir ist deutschland immer durchgelüftet
davor gekommen auch geistig wir waren ja
da auch im kessel es ist ja nicht die
schuld der österreicher wir waren im
kessel wir waren an drei seiten vom
eisernen vorhang umgeben wenn man
irgendwo hin gedacht hat dann nur nach
westen was anderes hat es nicht gegeben
aber dadurch ist so eine bestimmte
bunker situation auch entstanden und wie
es halt im gegensatz zu berlin auch eine
stadt mit einem fest umrissenen zentrum
das heißt wenn man in bestimmten
branchen kultur literatur journalismus
arbeitet
geht man dieselben kaffeehäuser also man
lebt dann irgendwie auch im dorf und da
wollte ich raus abgesehen davon dass
mein bruder mein großer bruder robert
menasse ja auch schon ein großer player
war in diesem kleinen elan ios heraus
und da wollte ich auch als wenn ich bin
20 mal am tag gefragt worden ob ich die
schwester genauso ich habe sozusagen
gefragt denn robert kann man wenn man
ihn fragt ob ich die tochter bin ja
jetzt endlich ja aber das gibt sich
trotzdem nicht auswirkte also ich wollte
aus vielen persönlichen gründen raus und
ich habe auch so eine befreiungs gefühl
in deutschland dann verspürt eben weil
die menschen in deutschland gewohnt sind
umzuziehen man die wenigsten menschen
also gerade akademiker sind wir immer
dort geblieben nein nein in ganz
deutschland immer so wären jetzt noch
von westdeutschland man hat nicht immer
man hat fast nie dort studieren können
wo man geboren worden ist also man hat
immer woanders hingehen müssen und dann
wenn man einen job gesucht hat man
wieder woanders hingehen müssen und
allein das macht mit den leuten schon
was ja ich hab mal den boshaften ich
liebe es zu boshaften satz geschrieben
in österreich geht man nach wien oder
man ist schon dort
mehr ist nicht das ist alles ein grund
gewesen rauszuholen
ebenfalls für eine zeit lang gestern
haben sie mir aber was gesagt dass wir
gemerkt dass er wird okay aber ich war
jetzt vor kurzem drei tage in wien und
dann habe ich etwas gemerkt was wir in
was mir in berlin fehlt in drei tagen
habe ich mehr gelacht als in einem jahr
in berlin
ja das ist weniger die schuld von berlin
sondern das ist die schuld von
deutschland ja ich verfolge die these
ich habe sie noch immer nicht bis zum
schluss durch gedacht ich verfolge die
these dass das beste und das
schlechteste an einem charakter immer
zusammenhängen und das wirkliche
verklebt sind das ist bei menschen so
und auch bei national charakteren in
gewisser weise und der deutsche ist auf
eine für mich als österreicherinnen
wohltuende weise vernünftig und seriös
und neurotisch im vergleich zu allen
nachbarn
wenn ihr das sprechen sie mir jetzt mal
ganz kurz nicht der österreicher ist
immer in so einem neurotischen
verhältnis zu sich selbst und seiner
definition und wir kleinen österreicher
und diese bösen großen deutschen und wo
ist unsere rolle und wir sind eigentlich
ganz toll aber niemand sagt und so also
das ist immer so ein distinktion problem
und minderwertigkeitskomplexe gepaart
mit hoffart dem schönen katholischen
wort aber durch seine seriosität
transparenz und gedankliche klarheit
fehlt dem deutschen der humor so ganz
grundsätzlich jetzt wirklich nur
national charakterlich besprochen und
der österreicher hat so eine
überschreitung mentalität deswegen sind
die österreicher manchmal so unerzogen
deswegen machen sie rassistische und
antisemitische und frauenfeindliche und
schwulenfeindliche witze aber humor
guter humor ist eben spielt immer mit
der grenze des erlaubten und geht
manchmal spielerisch darüber hinweg und
das erlaubt sich der deutsche schon
lange nicht mehr
und deswegen bin ich in österreich
manchmal genauso glücklich lachend wie
schockiert von dem was die leute so am
normalen wirtshaustisch raus lacht aber
trotzdem zu dem deutschland vernimmt wie
man die deutsche geschichte gibt gab es
ja eine teil wo es nicht ganz vernünftig
war ja was als 45 gibt es ein vernunft
der prozess ist es die verarbeitung der
geschicht darauf will ich hinaus ist
diese vernunft diese zurückhaltung etwas
hat es etwas zu tun mit einer
verarbeiteten mit einer charme auch von
einer geschichte die waren so
unvernünftig weil so schrecklich jetzt
keine überbordende emotionen mehr was
die österreichische natürlich nicht
geleistet haben was niemand geleistet
hat denn alle anderen auch die von
deutschland zurzeit besetzt und länder
haben erst vor zehn 15 jahren begonnen
ihre eigenen kooperations geschichten
aufzuarbeiten und warum ist das so weil
sich der mensch grundsätzlich nicht mit
seinen fehlern beschäftigen würde die
erhält sie haben weil sie deutschland
die einzigen waren
es mussten die mussten diese nicht davon
gekommen eine anderen konnten wie die
österreicher unfassbarer weise sagen wir
waren das erste opfer hitler und schon
unter dem nächsten peppig davon kriegen
ja in die neutralität die deutschen
durften nicht ich sage jetzt noch einmal
betont die westdeutschen die
westdeutschen durften das nicht dies
entwickelt zur sühne busse und durch
arbeiten gezwungen war ein sohn sagt
immer ja und ich deutsch sollte sich
darauf nicht ein bild die haben es nur
gemacht weil sie besetzt waren werden
sie nicht besetzt gewesen hätten sich
was sich so weit wie die österreicher
vollkommen richtig vollkommen richtig
trotzdem muss man vom ergebnis ausgehen
das ergebnis ist dass der dass
deutschland für mich im moment der
verlässlichste demokratische staat ist
weil dieses diese ganze arbeit die
geleistet worden ist die geht ja auch
durch die generationen durch das sind ja
jetzt schon junge leute die sind schon
so aufgewachsen da ist da ist was
passiert deutschland ist das einzige
land das keine wenn sie schauen
rundherum dass keine wie immer geartete
rechtsgerichtete partei hat die hoch
kommt das gibt es nicht aber ist anders
jeder rechtsgerichtete menschen die
kommen nicht politisch raus aber es ist
es ja gut aber der nsu prozesses ist
trotzdem so schrecklich das ist was sie
gemacht haben das betrifft diesen
kleinen bodensatz an gewaltbereiten das
ist eine insgesamt sehr kleine geschenke
die könnte in jedem anderen land genauso
etwas anrichten am ende waren das 10 15
leute die dann mitwisser und mithelfer
es gibt im deutschen kabarettisten der
ist tot
matthias beltz der kommt auch aus
unserer geschichte also meine geschichte
der hat mal eine vorführung plötzlich
der einst will ich euch sagen in
deutschland ist es leichter 6 millionen
bäume zu retten als sechs millionen
juden schon hart aber das würde heute
auch nicht mehr stimmen
das hat für damals gestimmt es hat sich
was verändert da da bin ich felsenfest
davon überzeugt schauen sie umgekehrt ja
wir haben uns von diesem ganz kleinen
prozentsatz gewaltbereiter
chris tischer neonazis geredet die
österreicher sind immer stolz darf
darauf dass es so etwas bei ihnen nicht
gibt und das stimmt auch wir haben keine
marodierenden glatzen die in
springerstiefeln irgendwelche
provinzhauptstädte terrorisieren wie das
immer noch in deutschland der fall ist
aber wir haben einen prozentsatz von 18
bis 25 prozent der wahlberechtigten die
erst eine partei wie die von jörg haider
wählen und dann in die oper oder ins
burgtheater gehen also die kann man zwar
nicht zu erkennen
sie machen auch was anderes aber
irgendwas muss ja in ihren köpfen sein
und ich habe manchmal die sorge dass es
tiefer in der gesellschaft drin ist viel
tiefer
weil es diesen hohen prozentsatz gibt
als eben in deutschland in deutschland
hat es bis heute keine partei gegeben
die irgend etwas ähnliches versuchte ich
mag die cdu/csu in manchen teilen ihrer
politik wirklich grauslich finden aber
das ist überhaupt in keinster weise
vergleichbar mit dem was in anderen
europäischen staaten ab geht ja es gibt
keine rechte parteien deutschland das ob
die deutschen das müssen haben und sonst
nicht gemacht hätten ist mir da ist mir
dann in dem moment auch egal dass ich
das ergebnis zählt
zwischen jänner und corsi christa lahm
sich ja in einer form die neuesten roman
ist oder dann ist es schwer lässliche
todsünden sie sich ja in
moralphilosophie habe ich nicht ich hab
literatur geschrieben okay wir haben die
terra tour geschrieben die aber sagen
wir es so auch sehr philosophisch
daherkommt oder über die grund im ohne
grund fragen der menschheit sich
auseinandersetzt also es sind todsünden
und dann ist es aber niedlich ist ein
bisschen österreich ist es letztlich
wozu ja das ist nicht nur ein bisschen
österreichisch sondern ich glaube die
dinge die sünden die die protagonisten
in diesen erzählungen begehen die werden
auf der ganzen welt sagen wir jetzt mal
legato möglich dieser titel ist dieser
titel ist von günther craß gut okay
weil er mir den sozusagen er hat seinen
sohn workshop jedes jahr lübecker
autorentreffen da lesen sich autoren
übrigens auch juli zeh war schon öfter
dabei aus ihren unveröffentlichten
manuskripten vor und da lese ich seit
jahren stelle ich meine arbeit voran der
ich gerade bin
und als ich die erzählung die erste
erzählung aus diesem band vorgelesen
hatte hatte ich noch kein titel und gras
hat gesagt das sind ja eigentlich
lässliche todsünden kannst du gleich als
titel danke herr k
ok hochmut also hochmut sagen was ist
hochmotiviert ist erstmal die
interessanteste dieser todsünden ist
auch die von den katholiken wenn es eine
rangordnung in diesen sieben todsünden
gibt dann hat die katholische
moraltheologie früher gesagt der hoch
modus der schlimmste weil der hoch und
richtet sich gegen gott für mich ist
hochmut diese dieser selbstermächtigung
sich das zu nehmen was man möchte also
sozusagen den anderen minder zu bewerten
als man selbst
aber hochmut ist bei ihnen der jazz ist
ja sehr nah an egoismus also das eigene
leid von dem der anderen stellen das
sind definieren sie als in dieser
geschichte in dieser geschichte
erschütternd ist demut dann genau das
gegenteil solidarität ja wobei das nicht
ganz stimmt aber dass das wäre so aber
die ich sage jetzt nicht dass diese
geschichte das ist was ich für hochmut
grundsätzlich habe mit der literarischen
erzählung nicht den hochmut jetzt
definiert also so will ich das nicht
verstanden wissen das ist eine
geschichte wo der leser denken kann aha
ist der mensch jetzt wirklich hochmütig
oder ist es was anderes so wie sie sagen
egoismus das eigene leid über das der
anderen stellen weil in ihnen also was
was mich interessiert in diesem buch
so wie ich das gelesen habe dass ich
fand das sehr existenzialistisch also im
grunde genommen an den wurzeln des
existenzialismus der mensch ist für sein
leben eigentlich verantwortlich er
entscheidet was er macht das ist richtig
und nur und trotzdem kann er sich nicht
dabei kontrollieren oder schlecht wenn
er kündigt aber woher kommen diese
sünden sind das einfach das leben
verleitet ein zum sündigen also gehen
sie mal ihr die sünden die für sie die
sechs wichtigsten sünden egoismus
rücksichtslosigkeit sechs wichtigsten
also wie soja und ist man genetisch
geizig ist man genetisch egoist jeder
mensch genetisch guide sich egoistisch
nein so ist das nicht
ich glaube dass die meisten menschen
sogar versuchen das alles nicht so seien
die wenigsten gehen ja jeden tag in die
welt hinaus und sagen so jetzt mach ich
mal wieder ein paar leute fertig sondern
jeder hat ja die gesellschaft leitet ja
auch an zu einem moralischen diskurs
jeder hat ja diesen wunsch sich sich gut
zu verhalten
trotzdem begeht man aus unachtsamkeit
aus unaufmerksamkeit aus gründen von
charakter aus auch wieder aus tagesform
einfach sünden am anderen indem man ihm
in seinen freiheiten beschränken dem man
in verrät oder beleidigt und man merkt
das gar nicht mehr deswegen heißt das
buch lässliche todsünden weil ich wollte
diese ganz kleinen übertritte
beschreiben wo sie wirklich so einem
homöopathischen bereich man in anderen
schädigt ohne es dabei richtig zu merken
gibt es den gutmenschen also doch nicht
der gutmensch ist ein echtes problem
wie gesagt der der erklärte schlecht
mensch der der sozusagen so durch die
welt geht und sagt ich bin schlecht
mensch und ich würde mich
fulda bei den muss man ja wirklich
suchen während der gutmensch eine
schreckliche um definition erfahren hat
in den in den letzten jahren gegründet
wurde der gutmenschen eigentlich aus
sehr guten gründen dass man eben
achtsamer sein soll also die ganze pc
politiker correctness debatte kommt ja
daher dass man minderheiten respektiert
dass man keine witze macht dass man dass
man behinderungen anerkennt und versucht
zu inkludieren in die gesellschaft das
hat alles sehr sehr gute und moralisch
hochstehende gründe
und dann gibt es um in eine übertrieben
in übertriebene kreuzzüge
die einen wollen nur mehr die
frauenrechte durchsetzen koste es was es
wolle und die anderen wollen jetzt die
sprache säubern
also es gibt aber so sind die menschen
leider sie entdecken irgendwas und dann
wollen sie auf die spitze treiben und
auf die spitze getrieben ist es schon
wieder schlecht sie sagen irgendwo in
einem interview wenn jemand sagen ich
bin kein antisemit sind sie schon auf
der hut ja natürlich das aber das kann
man also etwas lernt man sagen also ich
bin kein rassist kann man auch sagen
wenn jemand sagt ich bin kein ich bin
nicht homophob ich bin nicht
frauenfeindlich ich bin ich kinder weil
wir jedoch in viel kleineren bereich ich
habe vor kurzem auf einer lesereise mit
einem veranstalter gesprochen der von
einem wahnsinnig zickigen autor
berichtet hat der angeblich dauernd
gesagt ich bin ja nicht kompliziert aber
das hotelzimmer als zugleich ich bin
nicht kompliziert aber in diesem raum
werde ich nicht lesen
also die leute sagen ja mit dem
negationen schon immer sehr viel
übersicht sowie wir ja die ganze zeit in
wirklichkeit informationen über uns
selbst preisgeben ohne es zu merken und
gerade in diesen negationen ist es
besonders sichtbar warum sagt jemand ich
bin kein antisemit was für den grund hat
er diesen satz zu sagen weil er das
gefühl hat dass der andere denkt dass
antisemit ist aber da muss etwas
passiert sein vorher das überhaupt an
diesen satz kommt ja bei lässliche
todsünden bedeutet ja auch in diesem
zusammenhang mann
eigentlich nicht nicht antisemit oder
man kann nicht nicht schon freundlich
man kann es mehr oder weniger
zivilisatorisch verarbeiten aber
irgendwie gibt es reaktionen wo man dann
auf dem falschen fuß erwischt wird so
lese ich das ja aber ich möchte mich ja
erstmal schon gegen diese schubladen
wären denn es wird er fast jeder diskurs
der um juden oder israel geht in
deutschland mit der antisemitismus keule
geführt ja die hat ja dann jeder hat
diesen baseballschläger in der hand wo
draufsteht antisemit wir sind alle
menschen und wir haben alle
ressentiments
das gehört zum menschsein dazu da können
wir uns gar nicht wehren
wir müssen nur glaube ich daran arbeiten
sie zu erkennen und sie im zweifelsfall
auch aufzulösen und uns nicht gemütlich
dann auch noch hinein sacken zu lassen
in unserer ressentiments das ist glaube
ich die aufgabe die uns gestellt wird in
unserem leben aber schaffen werde es ist
wie wird das ohne genommen in der
öffentlichen debatte wie bringen wir das
rüber weil ich habe immer den eindruck
wir suchen eigentlich das korrekt war
wir sind die deutschen haben gelernt
aufgrund ihrer geschichte nie wieder
soldaten außerhalb von deutschland
wir sind geborene pazifisten nachdem wir
geborenen besatzer waren ich finde
wirklich also mit aller gebotenen
vorsicht dass man es an den deutschen
besonders gut beschreiben kann
weil die deutschen da so rein sind in
ihrem richtig machen wollen ja diese
deutsche vernunft führt immer da die
schweiz ja die schweizer kenne ich zu
wenig aber die schweizer sind die sind
ja auch sehr eigen die haben ihre ihre
kleine alpenfestung und da wollen sie
hier nicht raus und da wollen sie alles
so machen wie sie seit 500 jahren machen
also da da da ist das ist ein bisschen
anders geartet aber der deutsche die
hier immer die welt missionieren und das
will der schweizer zum beispiel nicht
geschadet ja der deutsche hat entdeckt
dass die mülltrennung den müll vermeidet
und am liebsten würde er
bei der uno feststellen lassen dass auf
der ganzen welt wohin der invention so
genau so so ist der deutsche der
deutsche irgendein deutscher
rechtsgelehrter kommt auf die idee dass
man beschneidung als körperverletzung
betrachten könnte und am liebsten
möchten sie das von der uno aus die
beschneidung auf der ganzen welt
das ist so dieses immer dieses
vorpreschen dieses musterschüler sein
und das gibt dann eben oft in diese in
dieser unangenehmen gutmenschen debatten
wie sie sagen mit mit mit krieg und also
man hat das und das gelernt daraus folgt
dass daran lässt sich nichts mehr
rütteln
aber die welt ist so dass es sich
verändert und dass immer wieder neue
seiten auf gehen die ambivalent sind und
da müssen wir hin gehen und müssen wir
schauen da dürfen wir nicht immer so
rechthaberisch auf den tisch hauen und
sagen es muss jetzt so gemacht werden
wir wissen seit dem nationalsozialismus
das dass wir dann zum beispiel dazu ich
liebe diese deutschen grotesken ja auch
sozusagen aus professionellen gründen
es führt dazu dass israel irgendwann mal
wieder in den libanon einmarschiert
daraufhin werden israelische
klezmermusik ausgeladen wie will man
dann auch nicht mehr haben ja also die
klezmermusik den israel keine rolle
spielt sondern nur die sozusagen eine
deutsche viele mieten folklore ist die
wird dann auch noch abgeschafft weil
irgend also es hat alles nichts mehr
miteinander zu tun
aber der deutsche hat das gefühl als auf
dem moralisch richtigen schied er aber
in der debatte ich finde es interessant
in der debatte über israel ist sind die
deutsch wie links wir echt total
überfordert ich eigentlich überhaupt die
sollten sich daraus die können doch gar
nicht dies sind aufgrund der
nationalsozialistischen vergangenheit so
moralisch überfordert dass es besser
wäre wenn sie sich raus geklappt aber
das macht im übrigen der die deutsche
regierung ungebrochen egal welche
regierung es ist die duh spiel ein ganz
ruhiges solidarität spiel hinter den
kulissen mit israel was ich richtig
finde und die machen da keinen wirbel
ja das stimmt nicht so ganz die
verhindern also wenn ich jetzt mal von
der europäischen ebene sehen die marken
im hintergrund verhindern die
auch vielleicht richtige maßnahmen die
man der israelische regierung mal zu
meinem sohn ja das ist ja also aus das
ist raus oder kollegen jahren korrekt
und nach joschka fischer hat wie immer
weil wir oft diskutiert habe ich gesagt
ihr müsst ja mal klartext mit der
israelischen regierung
das wäre dann der sie einmal gesagt
weißt du ich machen sollte ich zum
sharon da man es nicht angehen und
passen sie mal auf das was ihnen
besetzten gebieten machen das ist
unmenschlich sagt sie woher kommen sie
wer sind sie ja dass es heißt das dass
das ist das problem was dahinter steckt
ja die aussage dass es nicht geht in dem
besetzten gebiet ist richtig ja aber was
ist was eine deutsche aus sagt ich
wollte noch mal zu dieser identitäts
vorangekommen ist identität etwas was
man in seinem leben selber gestaltet
oder ist identität ein charakterzug aus
einem was angebot aus dem familiären
erleben oder etwas was sich natur
wirklich zusammen setzen was ist die
eigene tätigkeit in der ausbildung
meiner identität was kann ich machen was
kann ich sagen ich habe das verstanden
so war meine eltern ich habe die
geschichte aber ich will dass sein
ja das macht man glaube ich mit dem was
der mit dem beruf den man ergreift und
mit mit mit der art wie man sein leben
gestaltet man kommt ja es gibt ja
menschen die h kommen aus einem
elternhaus von dem sie sich am liebsten
100 prozentig entsolidarisieren wollen
also zum beispiel ein nazi elternhaus ja
wo man sich auch damit
auseinandergesetzt und dann wollen sie
unbedingt das absolute gegenteil machen
ja und wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
zugespitzt sage dann sind sie bei der
raf gelandet da waren sie nicht weil die
welt genau aber sie haben das gefühl
gehabt so sind komplett also sagen ich
will damit nur sagen das was wir
mitbekommen von unserer
familiengeschichte wie einen rucksack
dem schleppen wir weiter mit uns herum
und der bestimmt natürlich auch was wir
uns aussuchen und was wir liegen
also das kann man so glaube ich nicht
beantworten aber was feststeht oder was
für mich fest steht ablegen kann man das
nicht in einer form dass man sozusagen
wieder ein weißes unbeschriebenes blatt
papier werden könnte wann soll das sein
mit anfang zwanzig und dann macht man
was ganz anderes nein wir sind immer in
dieser interaktion mit dem was hinter
uns war und was wir wo wir hinwollen
aber ich bin mann oder sie sind frau ja
und aber es gibt jetzt völlig andere
gestaltung von mann oder frau und dieses
dieses erlebt man kann sagen so war
meine eltern so war mein vater so war
meine mutter am ende sind die
unterstellt man fällt sind die frauen
oder die männer von ganz anders sein als
ihre väter da ganz anders sein als die
mütter und am ende wenn sie
zurückschauen wenn sie selber 60 sind ja
so viel anders sehen wir auch nicht die
die die die kleinen die unterschiede
sind viel kleiner es gibt auch in
amerikanischen roman als ein mann der
mir jetzt nicht einfällt wer genau
dieses problematisiert also sie wollen
darauf hinaus dass es eigentlich kaum
spielraum gibt nein ich rede sein es
gibt spieler es ist eine frage die mit
einem shafiq es gibt spielräume
aber wie groß oder wie klein sie sehen
und wie viel kraft man braucht ja um
diese spielräume
wenn es nötig ist zu öffnen
das ist unheimlich schwer zu beurteilen
also ich habe den eindruck der
generation der 68er die ganz anders sein
wollten als ihre eltern und gebrochen je
älter sie werden desto im grunde
genommen
naja zurück oder nachsichtiger wohnt mit
ihren eigenen eltern
ich glaube es gibt eine vernünftige
mitte wie sich das leben gut führen
lässt
die kann ich nicht genau definieren die
muss jeder für sich definieren aber es
scheint mir in der geschichte so zu sein
eben die nazi eltern und dann die 68er
das sind beides extreme indies
ausgeschlagen hat und das will dann
wieder sich in
heute treffen also wenn der alte nazi
dann am ende seines lebens plötzlich das
gefühl hat das war doch nicht alles so
erklärbar was wir da gemacht haben
dann trifft sich das mit dem 68er der
dann im alter sagt das war schon ein
bisschen übertrieben und wirklich
teilweise auch völlig überzogen
das ist ein gesetz der der mitte das im
übrigen auch bei der
intelligenzforschung stimmt es heißt
immer dass genetisch es so ist dass er
etwas sagen wir mal sehr unintelligente
eltern und sehr intelligente eltern die
kinder sind nicht so wie die eltern das
ist über ganz kriege der große
denkfehler denn sarrazin auch gemacht
hat in seinem buch sondern es geht immer
zur mitte zu das heißt zwei
nobelpreisträger eltern wenn wir uns da
jetzt mal vorstellen kriegen er ein
mittel intelligentes kind ja und
umgekehrt und so ist es glaube ich auch
mit den erwartungen nur dem wie gesagt
wir sind menschen wir wollen immer wir
wollen immer den ganz großen wurf und am
ende unseres lebens glaube ich bemerken
wir dass es doch mal ein kleiner
geworden ist aber auf der alle seid ist
immer das leben ein großer wurf für
einen selber für einen selber aber die
frage ist wie man da rein geht es gibt
ja auch es gibt ja auch die menschen die
vor allem angst haben und die sozusagen
deren leben nur aus einer hinter der
deckung bleiben besteht ja die die die
sich führten und die keinen schritt
lieberlieber 2 zurück als eine nach vorn
machen für dies das leben kein großer
wurf sondern eine qual
das ist auch immer sehr individuell
sie haben aber trotzdem einen großen
wurf oder ist und das ist wirklich
unheimlich spannend ich uns hat auch im
volk ist auch schön
ja ich bedanke mich für dieses gespräch
verabschiede mich auch von den
zuschauern in der schweiz das waren
meine dritte veranstaltung oder
sendungen hier
vielen dank dass sie hier waren vielen
dank für das schweizer fernsehen das ist
mich eingeladen hat eva mach's gut danke
[Musik]
dieses gespräch finden sie wie übrigens
alle unsere gespräche immer auch online
oder sie bestellen es als dvd bei
schweizer radio und fernsehen redaktions
sternstunden 80 52 zürich die e mail
schicken sie an stern kabinett srf punkt
ch ob erdöl getreide oder kaffee die
schweiz ist eine wichtige drehscheibe
für den internationalen rohstoffhandel
doch die kritik daran wächst wir
sprechen über das heiße eisen
rohstoffhandel nächsten sonntag in der
sternstunde philosophie
jetzt aber zu kunst zu kunst die berührt
sie ist berühmt für ihren körper einsatz
marina abramovic 2010 saß sie drei
monate lang täglich sieben stunden auf
einem stuhl das wollten eine halbe
million menschen sehen wir zeigen den
film über marina abramovic